it's harvest time in Turkey entire
region every few minutes a truck arrives
at the my son company bringing crates of
fresh oranges hockey bahar heads up the
company which specializes mainly in
citrus fruit he hardly slept at all last
night the numbers on his desk are not to
his liking one big reason is that
business with Russia has collapsed an
export ban came into effect at the start
of the year my son also develops and
manufactures special-purpose machinery
for fruit farming things aren't running
smooth there either
why have you replaced everything a
component broke as we were working on it
the machines are tailor-made to suit
customer requirements they cost between
ten and twenty five thousand euros each
depending on the model and the number of
features we need to look at this the
transmission is broken and can't be
repaired some of the equipment was
destined for Russia but bahar says his
company can weather the current storm
the Russian market was still quite new
for us so our sales there were
relatively small Russia accounted for
only about one percent of our exports we
can make that up elsewhere my son is a
family-run company it's been selling
oranges for 40 years and oranges remain
the firm's core business peak season is
from October to May when up to 250 tons
of fruit passed through the packing
station each day bahar's pledged to the
customer is that all the fruit is fresh
delivered within just two days of
harvesting
Thanks so what do you see lots in the
middle not on the side I'll adjust it
you do that and fast otherwise you'll
have a problem
if the oranges aren't distributed evenly
the women working the sorting belt will
have to wait and that costs money during
the season there are two shifts a day
the sorters make sure only undamaged
fruit of the same size is packed into
the crates these crates are for don't go
they supply Turkish Airlines and
Lufthansa our oranges fly all over the
world but rarely to Russia these days
that's why my son is increasingly
dependent on sales to Europe the company
has 200 employees every day they pack up
around 5000 pallets like this one most
go to Germany and Austria but for my son
that's not enough long term in the
future we want to break into the British
market for three years we've been trying
to get a foothold in French supermarkets
we want to be able to deliver to Europe
from Europe to invest there and build up
logistic centers
fortunately the harvest season lasts
till May as long as the oranges are not
picked they remain fresh but they won't
stay good forever my son needs to find
new customers soon